8 news now has been following the
changes that are happening at share
village today our community stepping up
and offering help to those veteran
residents christian kosarus joining us
live in our studio with how one person's
act of kindness really christian made a
big difference that's right brian it's
amazing how one person can make a big
impact and that was the goal for regina
mckay and her team who tell us they just
wanted to help
it was smiles and laughter inside cher
village today as several veteran
residents were treated to a barbecue the
low-income residential complex has been
going through a rough phase after their
landlord walked away from the property
due to coveted health problems residents
tell us maintenance and many services
have slowly faded away over the past
weeks regina mckay is with we care for
seniors of nevada and says she wanted to
help they was shocked you know one lady
started crying you know
everybody was just happy you know they
was like always so happy they say they
hear about a lot of people you know
that's going to do for them but nobody
ever show up very appreciative of what
they're doing you know because of our
situation we just found out that
our management is gone residents were
treated to hot dogs cheeseburgers energy
bars and drinks mckay tells us she hopes
to make this a regular visit while the
residents are in need
a lot of happy residents today we have
been in touch with arnold stock who runs
share village he tells us they are in
talks with the property owners on how
they will move forward christian casadas
8 news now